so I'm tally and I'm gonna talk about
structured data and data set and queries
but they'll be pit stops on associations
and how do I use them to do interesting
things in Mathematica so we've all known
that Mathematica can be a great platform
for doing data science and for doing
kind of experimental analytics and
prototyping things and doing great
interactivity and visualizations but one
of the weak points until now has been
that it's hard to deal with very large
data sets in a way that is kind of
ergonomic and friendly and they're kind
of many reasons for that one is that
it's hard to sort of see what you're
doing if there's too much on the screen
and it can slow down your front-end to
have all that data kind of coming back
at you and another kind of point along
those lines is if something goes wrong
it can be very hard to see what went
wrong because of the kind of infinite
evaluation semantics of the language if
things don't evaluates they can kind of
spew and go crazy and you end up with a
lot of unavailable codes spread across a
large data set that can be disastrous
for getting things done and debugging
what went wrong so starting in version
10 there's a new construct to make it
easier to work with structured data and
to help you reason about things and help
you Express powerful queries and that
construct is called data set it takes
some inspiration from similar constructs
in other languages like you have data
frames for example but there's a very
different philosophy behind them which
I'll talk about in in a bit of detail so
here's an example of a data set and it's
kind of pretty simple to see what's
going on here there's a bunch of columns
those columns are named and we have rows
that contain the data so far you know
that should be pretty straightforward
what's what gets interesting is that you
can express in a very concise syntax
powerful queries against that set of
data so this particular data set is from
passengers of a Titanic you might have
seen it in their tens talk yesterday
about machine learning it's kind of a
typical machine learning dataset people
try things out on sort of demo things so
here you can see we're doing some some
little queries so what this query here
is asking how many of the age fields in
those rows how many of those are missing
and we can see that's quite a few of
those ages are missing or we can we can
do a histogram of a particular field so
if we get all the ages of passengers on
the Titanic what what does that look
like you can see most of them are 22 23
we can do something a bit more involved
so we can count how many people fell
into the different passenger classes
sure actually I'm gonna take a quick
break and set the resolution a bit lower
because that works better it might not
help very much
I prefer to do that rather than zooming
in zooming can change the way things
line break or whatever but is that big
enough it's actually a bit too big I
want to zoom out again sir
so here are we saying in the Titanic
data set I want to find out how many
passengers fall into first class second
class third class but also I want to do
that on a per SEC's basis so from four
men and four woman and that's again
that's quite concise to do that and the
last point which touches on what I
mentioned earlier is that instead of
kind of like going haywire if something
doesn't make sense if you write a query
that's of inapplicable then we will give
you a nice symbolic failure that you can
use to try to rewrite your query in a
way that makes sense so here I'm asking
for a column that just does not exist in
the data set and it just tells me right
away that it can't do that it gives me a
hint about what what I could change so I
could change that column to age or sex
source or survive because those are the
columns that are available so before we
go into more depth I should talk about
lists and associations because that's
the kind of like fundamental building
blocks that you use to model data with
data set in the Wolfram language so you
know everyone knows lists they're kind
of foundational and we've had them since
the beginning it's important to point
out that let's serve the sort of dual
purpose on one hand they can contain an
arbitrary number of elements and you
kind of use that to represent the same
thing again and again and again like all
the ages all the sexes another point is
that you can also use them in a sort of
fixed way where the length might be the
same so length too in this case and the
first part means something different
from the second part it's not like the
interchangeable bobbin sueanne's it's
interchangeable Jane and five are not
interchangeable so that's kind of one
thing to keep in mind we'll see examples
of that later
and now associations that new and ten
they're used to represent records or
associative arrays things where you have
parts that you want to index by an
expression so you want to talk about
sort of age or sex not just part one
part two and you can see
again you can see two examples they sort
of mirror what happened with lists you
can have associations where it's the
same basic pattern repeated again and
again here we're mapping names to ages
for example and you can see the other
case which is a fixed association that
has fixed fields name age sex you can't
add another sex there it changes the
meaning the value male is different from
the value 30 so that's that same kind of
distinction between two uses of the same
data structure so this is what I want to
zoom in because that data set there's
very small that's what happens when you
miss with with formatting sorry about
that but with data set the point is that
you can nest these things infinitely to
express all different kinds of shape of
data structure so in a typical case
you'll have lists of associations which
represent tables but anything's possible
and I'll give examples of those anyway
the point is yeah so I've covered this
association I want to go in a bit more
detail to how associations work and the
functions that operate on them because
that again there's like really important
for actual getting stuff done the number
one operation obviously is to look up
values corresponding to specific keys
and the many ways of doing that
the simplest way is to just use
Association as if it were a function so
I've defined an association here that
has keys a B and C and I'm looking up
key a by just applying the Association
to a but I can also use parts and texts
so here I'm saying part normally I would
say like one or two all but in the case
of an association in general you have to
use this wrapper key to kind of indicate
that that a there is to be interpreted
as the key of the of the Association you
can also use a function call to look up
and so look up take some Association on
the key and looks it up what's cool
about lookup is that it's kind of
threads in all these different ways so
you can provide a list of keys and
you'll get back a list of the
corresponding values or you can provide
a list of associations and you'll get
back again a list of values and if you
do both you'll get back a kind of matrix
where the rows are each of the
associations and the columns are each of
the keys and the last cool thing what
lookup is it gives you an opportunity to
define a default value
if the key is not found instead of
getting back missing which is the normal
default to default default you can
define your own default so I might want
to know something that you know if it's
numeric maybe zero is a reasonable
default or some later step in my in my
algorithm so another really common
operation is counting things and
associations are great for that because
the thing that you're counting is kind
of naturally wants to be a key and the
count naturally wants to be a value that
means you can then look up how many
times did they occur how many time is to
be occur the cons function does that so
we got a list of items and we get back a
list of of counts they occurred five
times B occur two twice you can use
counts by to kind of like parameterize
your count based on the output of that
function so here I want to know that you
know of those 20 numbers between 1 and
20 12 of them were not prime and 8 and 1
prime group by gives you a way to group
elements in a list into different two
different groups each group will be the
value of a key so in this case prime Q
you know they're two possible outputs of
prime future and false and we can see
those things that fell into the class
false and the things that fell into the
class two now I'm showing you a little
bit of syntax here that's again that's
new and ten and that's four slash star
that's something called a right
composition and that makes it really
easy to chain together multiple
functions to make one kind of compound
function and right here in this case it
means I'm going to take the divisors of
each integer I'm gonna count how many
devices that are with length and then
the combination of those things just
gives you you know how many divisors an
integer has so one has one divisor two
has a to three and five and seven of two
divisors because they're prime etcetera
you can also do this thing you can
provide an operation to apply after
you've grouped the elements so you can
say you know I want to group these
things by their first element so that's
the first there but after I've done that
I only care about the second element and
so I'm going to use last a kind of like
post-process each of those those
elements in the group
you can nest groups so you can keep
grouping on different predicates at each
step here we first gathering things
based on whether they're prime and then
we just separating them into those that
are less than ten and there's the
greater than ten so those are the primes
and then here's whether they less than
or greater than ten the last kind of
very powerful addition to this mixture
is that you can give a reducer and a
reducers then use to kind of collect
together all the different results and
and summarize them in some way so here
we are grouping things that aren't in
our prime between one and twenty and
then we serve totaling them up so you
can see the total of things that are
prime with 77 and the ones that weren't
prime we're on 33 and you can actually
use that to define counts by if you want
so how do you combine associations well
there different ways of doing it
depending on what kind of behavior you
want so if you just want to sir mash
them together and have the keys fight it
out if they duplicate keys you can use
associate Association itself as the
combiner so if I just put an association
inside another association with multiple
associations inside another Association
they kind of glue themselves together to
make one big Association and the
semantics are that the rightmost value
wins if they're multiple keys the
rightmost one will be the one that gets
used so here I have two associations
that share the key C but the second one
has four for the value the first one has
three fours the one that one you can use
the merge function to collect things
together and then decide what to do with
them yourself so we saw that C was the
one that was in common and so both
values I think I need to reevaluate that
sure both values show up there there's
three and four there and I can do
different things I could only take the
three by using first I could use
something like total to kind of add them
up it's up to you how you want to how
you want to kind of reconcile these
different associations now there's like
a lot more I'm not showing you but this
is meant to be fast so there's lots of
functions for dealing with keys but I
won't go into the one that's kind of
particularly relevant for dealing with
datasets is here
and what that does is fill in any keys
that are missing across a list of keys
so if you have sort of sparse data not
all these are present then you can fill
in the keys that aren't there by using
here in and it detects what key is it
should add there's a kind of dual of
that which is key intersection that
finds the keys that are actually are in
common between all of them and it drops
all the other keys now you can do stuff
that's kind of equivalent to operations
in sequel I won't go too much into that
because it's like it's actually a
different track from the track that data
set takes but if you do need that
functionality it's there in the form of
joint across which you can read all of
art in the documentation so I'm actually
gonna do something here I don't like the
fact that this formatting is is
different in stylesheet mode I'm going
to go back to working mode and it should
look like how I originally designed it
yeah looks better oh there's another
little thing we need to get through
before we should kind of launch into a
data set and that's the notion of an
operator form so these are again a new
and ten kind of inspired by what we
needed for data set to be concise and
elegant and the way to think about them
is they're if you're familiar with
currying in other languages this is our
take on currying so there's a kind of
list of many dozens of functions in
Mathematica that existed before but now
have an operator form and I'll give an
example of an operator form quickly
let's look up something like math
that's too small I should presume in
there so you know everyone's familiar
with map it's workhorse function but now
map has this operator form and the idea
with an operator form is it's it's the
operation without having been applied
it's kind of symbolically represents the
act of mapping a function over something
over an expression and it acts like a
function so once you've got this
operator form you then just apply it and
it'll evaluate like an ordinary map word
if you'd written two arguments so let's
go back okay so to kind of justify why
we want that I want to take you a little
detour through sort of the different
style of code that it unlocks that you
can write not with operator forms so
this is just a very kind of simple
example we're taking the text in Allison
I want to land and we want to count find
the most frequent words so we want to
remove words that like a boring words
like then and and and a and so on we can
get that from word data and now we're
going to use this kind of nested set of
function calls to find those most common
functions there's most common words and
sort them in order of their appearance
and take the top ten now that's fine and
if you sort of familiar with you know
the style of coding it's probably not
too hard to figure out what's going on
there but I think it can be better and
operator forms sort of give you a way of
making it happen so the way to read this
of course is inside art because that's
how it evaluates first you find the
inner most things drink split that
evaluates into a list of words to lower
case low cases all the words delete
cases removes the trivial words and so
on and so on
unfortunately it's a bit weird because
that's not how you naturally want to
read things you can't really easily find
the inside to to kind of read it inside
out if you want to change things than
editing a bracket like immediately
destroys the syntax correctness of that
piece of code and then you have to kind
of like find the matching bracket now
that it's gone to take it out to do
something else like that so if you want
to rearrange the order of things if you
want to edit or delete things it can be
very hard to deal with these nested
expressions in sort of
friendly and very ergonomic you have
some tools at your disposal to make it
easier you can use in a prefix or
postfix forms like at and forward slash
forward slash but that only gets you so
far
but with operator forms you can boil
down the sequence of operations into a
beautiful pipeline that reads from left
to right in a very English like way so
here's the abstract operation we're
doing first we splitting up the string
into words we're locating those words we
are deleting the trivial words we're
counting them then we're sorting the
results then we're reversing that sort
of thing because it's in the wrong order
and lastly we're taking ten elements now
that's really nice and readable and the
only nesting I had to use was for take
that's because take does not support an
operator form
it's a varargs function although we
don't usually use that fact because it's
varargs we don't know that take ten on
its own could be an operator form take
tens valid it just means don't do
anything far augs means it can have a
verbal number of arguments so an example
would be you can keep writing things
here technically but it's very few
people actually use that now there's the
stuff that this unlocks I mean for one
thing what I've written has a valid
function so we don't even need to define
a function with the Donne value we can
just set that to assemble and we have a
valid function we can use we can also do
things interesting things like return
and new functions so we can have
functions that return functions that's
certainly possible to do at the moment
but it gets more idiomatic when you have
these very clean symbolic
representations of compound operations
and the last thing is a bit more of an
abstract point it's that it's harder to
if you want to think about processing
the function in the abstract if you want
to think about a chain of operations
maybe you want to optimize those
operations find a different order that
does the same thing but that execute is
faster it's hard to do that against pure
functions if pure functions is the way
that you've represented these comp is
calm
and operator then you have to sort of
pattern match inside for your functions
look inside them and instead of
inelegant
and in some cases it's impossible to
know exactly what a peer function will
do what the fact that a pure function is
the same as another one the variables
might be different slots might be named
differently so it's kind of it's cleaner
to have a symbolic representation of
operations as you can patent match on
you can process in a clean symbolic way
so as a kind of little sort of hint at
what we're working on if you want to
start rewriting these these operations
into something like sequel it's just
quite natural to do that if you have
operator forms if you have big messy
pure functions it's sort of a lost cause
okay so we have the ingredients we need
to look at some practical data sets the
one I've already mentioned the Titanic
data set the thing to understand about
it is that any kind of data can fit in a
data set if it's structured if it's kind
of has the same consistent in a way that
it's structured then it'll work but
there are certain kinds of certain
shapes of data that have special meaning
to data set in that they format in a
kind of a familiar way so here we have I
don't know if everyone can see that I
can make that image bigger if I need to
here we have this familiar table
underneath it stored as lists of
associations well that should feel
natural all right it even prints in a
way that's kind of reminiscent of a
table each particular Association is an
observation sorry go ahead
that's a feature that's coming I mean in
this particular example there are no
missing elements like that's the
entirety of it but for bigger datasets
it does allied rows you can't see all of
them at the moment but that'll get
better in the future the key point is
that each Association has an observation
so you that it's natural to have a row
be an association because a row is the
unit of analysis that you typically want
to use you can select you can map over
these things you know that's it's the
right thing it's kind of logical for to
model your data as a list of
associations if this is what it is now a
little variation on that is an
association of associations so here we
have you'll notice what's different
about this is this is this new column on
the left and that column contains keys
and that's kind of why it's darker it's
because just like before the the the
headers indicated keys now the the rows
the leftmost column indicates we have
keys here and that's because the
corresponding data is an association of
associations and the keys and the outer
association are the names of these rows
that kind of named rows and then again
it's the same story inside the keys
inside each Association correspond to
columns so here's it's like conceptually
you've just labeled each observation
that's all that's happening and what's
nice about that of course is it lets you
easily look up individual observations
or if you select them out you can tell
which ones you got that kind of thing
here's a little bit more of a
complicated one it's actually simpler in
some sense there are no associations we
found at all here we just have lists of
lists and the first element of each list
is the first column and so on that's how
it maps out on to the data set that's
common if you're doing something very
lightweight and you don't want to bother
naming things so how do you construct
data sets I've shown you how they format
but how do you construct them and how do
you get them into the system well the
first way is just manually in the
language itself so here I'm making a
list of associations and they will have
the same keys they have n square Prime
and so on and if I wrap that in data set
then that list of associations gets
turned in today's that object that
stores that same data but now it will
format it for me and it will let me
write queries on it you can also import
files into data sets using functions
like semantic import so what semantic
import does is look sort of a file or
TSV or CSV file that you have and tries
to figure out what the columns are tries
to figure out if certain columns have a
specific interesting semantic type
something like country for example will
use some of the sort of natural language
understanding technology that we have in
alpha we've sort of shipped that to you
in the form of semantic import you can
locally at high speed parse these
interesting things things like countries
dates times
cities even famous people and they will
turn into these rich entity objects in
the language inside a data set
so text and then data set in which we've
we know what these countries are and you
can then use all the power of the
Wolfram knowledge base to to do
computations with them and the last way
of getting things in is from alpha
itself from the knowledge base if you
use the entity value function you can
ask for the results to come back in the
form of data set so here I'm looking up
a list of entities and a list of
properties countries in Europe GDP
population country code that I'm getting
them back formatted as an index table
and data set so to discuss queries I
want to kind of lead you through how we
got to them Perry's are these I've
alluded to them they concise ways of
doing interesting computations on data
sets but they build off on something
that's already in Mathematica and
Wolfram language that everyone's
familiar with and that's part syntax so
part syntax is a very flexible thing
parts index is based on the fact that
the full form of any expression is kind
of uniquely addressable you can talk
about the third part of a list and but
more importantly you can nest these part
specifications so if I say part of
expression p1 p2 p3 then each of those
Peas is talking about a part within a
level of a hierarchical expression and
in the world of associations that just
carries over very simply
instead of using integer parts you can
use string keys and those allow you to
talk about the value corresponding to a
certain key in a hierarchical expression
so let's do some simple examples we've
got a function tally tally takes a list
of elements and gives you back lists of
pairs of each element and it's count
this is really basic stuff but but it'll
we'll we'll keep going can take the
first such pair the second you can take
from all the pairs the first element
from all the pairs the second element
you can see how that kind of multi-level
specification is very powerful I mean
just obviously immediately it's very
powerful now when you bring associations
into the mix it gets more interesting so
I'm starting with a kind of column or
into table so we have an association
whose values of Lists and if I transpose
that Association I will get a list whose
values or associations there's just an
easier way to write it for this example
but it's also it might be interesting to
see that you can do that this should
happen without an option so for now
we're being cautious we have this option
you use but we might change the
semantics of that so that you don't need
an option to do that now that I have
this table lists of associations I can
look up the age of the first Association
I can look up all the ages I can look up
both age and sex and when you do this
when you provide a list of parts you get
back a sub Association so we preserve
the fact that there's an association
there and we drop whatever keys you
didn't mention in that list
now the core idea of queries is that we
just take that those recursive semantics
that hierarchical semantics of part and
we extend them to work with not just
parts but with any number of operations
like any operations you want selecting
things sorting things taking summaries
of things with things like total and
mean all those functions now have a
meaning in the context of a sort of part
specification and that's what query does
so some very simple examples I'm not
going to show you the output because
I'll show you later some very simple
examples of what a query looks like on a
data set titanic's the data set and I
use sort of function application syntax
I give this what I've written here is a
part specification like all-age that
would work on a list of associations
without any data set involved at all but
I can change that all to a select
operator form there's the select
operator form this is saying I want to
take only those rows for which age is
greater than 30 and for those rows I
want to then take the survived key value
and that's the kind of that's all it is
really it's just extending part syntax
with function application so let's take
a look at more detail at how this works
the way to understand it is that each
subsequent specification in your query
corresponds to a deeper level of the
data set so at level one we have the
list itself the Artemus list of these
associations at level two we have each
Association and at level three we have
the values in each Association so when I
write a query like all comma H all
because it's the first thing corresponds
to the utmost level so we want
everything from that list but what are
we going to do to each thing in the list
well we're going to take age so again
age is now referring to each Association
so we look up in each Association age
and that's that's why we get those
values but we could go further we could
apply something to the age itself once
we've got each age we could apply
something further so now I'm going to
round each a
age to the nearest you know 10 and
that's the result we see so a different
kind of query we might select the rows
we don't want to take all the rows now
we want to just select those rows that
have some property and from those rows
we will take from each Association we
will take the age and so that's the kind
of general shape of how things work
I'll now kind of run into some examples
these in the documentation so you can
look them up anytime you want the good
examples are which is one copying again
we start with the Titanic dataset we can
just ask for the length so Titanic is a
list of associations it's nothing wrong
with asking for the length of a list
we'll see that there 1309 people we can
sample those so we can get you know five
random passengers that's again a data
set if we want to see the data behind
the data set or inside the data set we
can use normal to get that and again you
see it's just lists of associations we
can count the number of associations
that have the value missing for age we
can count the number of passengers in
each class we can get a histogram of the
ages this is more interesting so we're
now taking again a histogram of the ages
I'm gonna customize what that histogram
does so I want to use bins of size 4
between 0 and 80 but I want to do
something else too I want to
parameterize the result by the passenger
class so if I just drop this this is a
developing version so this might break I
have an idea yeah that works so if I
just run it like this I'm getting a
histogram of all the ages but if I add
in a group by I'm now getting resolved
it has an extra level of Association and
that extra level of Association tells me
which passenger class is this histograms
that are conditioned on and I could just
go if I wanted to I could keep adding I
could do another one for sex if there so
it took my fancy you can see that that's
the beginning of something quite quite
powerful the list goes on but maybe I
should kind of skip ahead here he has a
different kind of this is a more there's
more structure in this data set it's
kind of outside the realm of what you
typically find in in you know a
spreadsheet or a CSV file
so here we have a planet's data set and
you can tell from the the grey column on
the left that this is an association of
associations but there's something else
going on which is that one of the fields
the moon's field has another table
embedded in it and it's hard to format
that without making the whole table so
big that you can't actually effectively
read anything but so we give you a look
kind of a lighted summary we might show
you the first couple of values and then
we show you a little dot dot dot to let
you know that there's more stuff but
it's there and you can then start
getting that out so let's look at the
mass of the earth that's very simple
it's just the row earth the column mass
that's its value but now we can look up
one of those sub tables so what are the
moons of Neptune well there's the table
we can fully format it not because we
don't of anything else any other
structure around this we can keep going
so let's get all the radiuses radii
let's make a bar chart of the radii so
now we have three things we're finding
the moon's getting for all the planets
take the moon's and then give me the
number of moons the length of moons the
length of that list a pie chart of that
so now yeah we're going to compute a
result and then use that result in
another query so I'm going to get out
the mass of Earth's moon and then once I
have that I'm going to select only those
moons from other planets that are more
than twice there are more than half the
mass of our moon and then I'm doing
something interesting here I don't want
to see all the extra information about
those moons I just want to see what they
are so I'm going to use keys there
that'll take that Association of
associations just give me the keys just
the names of those moons so I can see
you know earth obviously the moon is
twice it's half its mass as more than
half its mass Jupiter you know a couple
of heavy moons there etc the maximal
operator by which I haven't mentioned so
far lets you find the subset of a list
or Association that maximizes some
property or value so he I'm asking for
of each of the sets of moons for all the
planets which of those moons are
heaviest and zan ark you know in our
case there's only one sits near the moon
it's Ganymede titantron etc okay I could
go on but maybe I should just keep going
and try to get to a different topic yeah
so in all of this there's something kind
of interesting going on behind the
scenes that if you've worked with
datasets you might even have encountered
this ready there's a kind of a
distinction in when you write these
queries when you write to kind of all
these operators one after another some
of them they fall into two classes some
of them behave in a descending fashion
and so them behave in an ascending
fashion and what that means is that when
the result is being recursively computed
sometimes you want to perform an
operation before you recurse down and
other times you want to perform an
operation after you've already recurse
down and come back up again
that sounds very abstract but I'll I'll
give a simple example to make it clear
what the difference is so we've got a
very simple data set here this is three
columns h6 and where this one is
employed let's look at the query max
coma age so we know what all comma H
does just gives me the list of ages if I
do max comma age it makes sense that I
have to wait until I've got the list of
ages before I can apply a max I can't
apply max to the associations themselves
because you know what's max of true and
false so I've got to take the ages I've
got to go further along the query get
the ages before I come back to the left
to the left and then compute max on the
results on the sub results but I can
show another example of where the
opposite had to happen so here I
actually wanted to do the selection
first I want to select those rows those
people for which their age is greater
than 20 before I look up their sex
I could do it afterwards actually but
it's just more efficient to first get
the rose I'm interested in and then do
something to those rose look at the the
sex field so how does this work well the
answer is that some operators don't make
sense if you apply them before you do
subsequent operators so I've really give
an example max does not make sense to
take max and then recurse into what
you've got it just doesn't make any
sense so it turns out that it's sort of
like natural sort of all these different
operators naturally cleave into those
that make sense
to do ascending versus those that make
sense to do descending and that's what
we've done so they kind of automatically
work in a way that you that they need to
be to be useful to you now some of them
you know it might take a while to kind
of get used to the semantics of a
sending and descending but once you do
it is it is fairly natural you can even
do things like combine descending and
ascending operators and the descending
part will be done before you take age
and then the a selling part will be done
after you have got the age okay now it
can still get tricky and for the most
part dataset will stop you shooting
yourself in the foot if you write an
invalid query that just doesn't make
sense will we won't even execute it'll
give you feedback that what you wrote
didn't make sense and and that will help
you to kind of figure things after
yourself but in the future we might
provide all kinds of put a predictive
interface mechanisms that kind of give
you feedback as you write a query that
autocomplete the things that you can do
at a certain level of your of your data
set and that should make it like really
foolproof to to write complicated
queries so I thought I've sort of
described data set and giving some
examples of how it works
I could go into a little bit about what
it's doing behind the scenes but also
maybe now's a good time to answer any
questions if anyone has any questions
I've been thinking about it a little bit
I think it might make sense to have a
structure called multi Association and I
think the strongest case for it is where
there's no natural nesting order like a
good example sort of be census sort of
data you know like it it doesn't matter
which way you split things up they're
all the different dimensions in some
sense that are commute to each other and
it yes it might make sense to have and
then the promise we would make is that
you can look up on any of those keys and
it'll be equally efficient no matter
which key you pick the thing we would
have we do I don't think we want to go
as far as mimicking a sequel like I
don't think like each of those things
should be unique I think that's a
restriction that we would want in force
so whenever you use anything that's like
not whitelisted in other words
explicitly known to be descent because
descending operators have this very
special property that after they've done
something it still makes sense to
recurse into the result like select it
doesn't change the shape of what of what
its input was it might make it smaller
but the shape is the same that's why it
makes sense for selected to be
descending but if you write your own
operator that you think should be
descending there are kind of not hockey
but a pea quay is to make it
artificially descending and I can I can
show you those but maybe we should add a
head to call descending that lets you
kind of explicitly call out what you
want to do yeah so I think that's a weak
point at the moment honestly I mean with
you know in the relational world it's
kind of very very natural to combine
things we do provide join across but
join across is kind of almost like I was
sort of poor a cousin of the rest of the
functions there it's it does do to the
letter what sequel does in these
situations but what makes things more
complicated for us is that not only do
you have sort of lists of associations
you might also have associations of
associations what's the natural way to
join there like there's that's something
where there's one primary key you know
like we want
to unlock their very natural semantics
for how to combine different datasets
and especially how to combine datasets
deeper than at the top level so if you
have you know one data set and you like
deep inside it's referring to another
data set it's using a value that turns
out to be the primary key for some other
data set it should be really natural
than I'm chained in and to keep working
and I haven't quite figured out the
semantics of how that should work but if
you have suggestions I would have anyone
has suggested that I'd love to hear them
so 1000 2 is very close it's not much
time left there's some stuff at the end
that that you might be interested in so
stick around so
just to what yeah yeah yeah that's
totally right yeah so the widow age
comma max yeah no because there's no
there's no level they're like these are
talking specifically about levels in the
original data set I mean you you this is
really good point you brought this up
because what we're really doing here I
mean the way to think about the way I
like to think was maybe it'll be
technical or the way I like to think
about what a dataset query is doing
there's a little like machine that's
sort of eating away at the data set and
sort of recursing art and making copies
of itself at each level and by ending a
query and starting a new query you reset
that machine to start again at the top
instead of trying to force it to do
exactly what you want within one query
and that can be clearer to sort of stop
have an intermediary result and then
process that intermediary result again
like with like what we're doing here yes
so it's lower and it just intrinsically
cannot ever be as fast because that the
evaluation semantics are clear like this
thing evaluates before this has a chance
to do anything so we can't optimize
anything there there might be a solution
to that though okay so sorry one more
question
I mean up values as a kind of way of
implementing associative arrays I mean
you're right yeah their associations are
less flexible in that sense that you
can't use them to define functions with
patterns but what I would say is that up
Ferries was such a kind of grotesque way
of achieving associative array behavior
in the language because they were so the
kind of global they're stateful they're
not immutable they don't have any of the
properties that you want in a functional
language whereas associations have all
of those properties you know they
encapsulate all their state and to just
the expression itself and you know you
can if you pens to it you'll get another
Association and the old ones still there
and those those properties are really
important yeah so as far as I'm
concerned like you we you win in a big
way okay so done a much time so I want
to rush through this so I mentioned that
operator forms of this what's really
nice about them they're symbolic you can
look at them you can pattern match on
them they represent they don't just
behave a certain way they represent that
behavior in a robust stable way and it
turns out that queries just compose
operator forms that's all that they do
when you have this kind of this
hierarchical query it just boils down
into a bunch of nested operator forms I
think it's really clean and elegant
effect so we can take a look at some
examples you've seen all of these so far
all right you've seen map and selections
and all these operator forms there's one
that you haven't seen that slice the way
to express that a slice is that operator
form of part parts of our arcs so we
can't make an operator form for it but
if we could it would be slice it's like
you will see slice come up it's not a
system symbol it's in some context but
I'm hoping to find a way to to make it a
system symbol to find some something we
can all agree would be good to have in
the core language so I will make some
statements and then
we'll show you the sort of general
result so he has some particular
equivalences so the query or common F is
equivalent to the operator form map F
and to make it clear here two of them
doing the same thing giving the same
result so I'm preserving everything at
the top level and at the inner level I'm
applying F and of course that's the same
as map F how could it not be now I've
got selective F so I'm selecting things
according to some predicate and then I'm
doing G to each of those things that's
again that's equivalent to select F
composed with map G so first I'm
selecting things and then afterwards I
am mapping G across what remains and
there's just to prove it's the same
thing all comma key is equivalent to
slice all comma key so again slice is
just part so obviously that's a part
syntax so of course it's the same now it
turns out that you know once you've
figured out ascending descending and you
have lists of which things are
descending it's very easy to compile any
query into one of these compound forms
so in version 1000 to you this is
explicit like you can get out what the
compiled form is if you want to see it
and here's some examples so all F that's
the compiled form these are just I'm
just repeating what you saw earlier and
here's a slightly more complex example
I'm selecting something I'll get out a
list of things and then from each thing
I still want to take key what's really
nice about these is that you have the
potential to optimize these guys once
you've got up these sort of compound
operators that sum up what you're going
to do you can then start applying
identities and figuring out the best way
to to execute that that query I don't
have time so I won't go into the types
is actually a huge amount here probably
half an hour's worth of material to talk
about so underneath data set in order to
help you not write invalid queries and
to format the data set in a sort of an
intelligent way and in future to start
doing things like compiling the queries
down into the machine code or
sort of other other things like the war
from virtual machine in order to do that
we need to know what the shape of the
data set is and that's being modeled
behind the scenes and I'll briefly show
you if we look at the Titanic data set
I'm just going to random sample it so we
can see it's not going to be too big if
I take input form of this then I can see
that the first argument is the data
there's all the data and then the second
argument is a type description of that
structure so this is a compound type
obviously it's a vector of structs and
then there's more information about
individual columns their atoms of of
some of them are integers some of them
are strings boolean's and so on and you
can do really interesting things with
these types that's a whole nother talk
that maybe I should give at some point
about the usefulness of such a type
system for the rest of language as well
it doesn't impose anything on you you
don't you're not forced to do anything
you don't even know that it's there
actually but it does have the smarts to
stop you writing invalid queries and
help format things and to optimize
things the general thing that this is a
form of is known as an algebraic data
type system I would love to show you
what that's like
yeah there's no I have three minutes
left so it's gonna have to wait I want
to talk a little bit about what's coming
up so it's clear that there's a sort of
zoo of different lists Association
related functions that need to exist to
help you push and pull at the shape of a
data set to get it exactly how you want
so the most pressing one I think is to
take an unindictable just a list of
associations to turn it into an index
table and Association of associations
and back again like it's such a simple
operation and it's frustratingly
difficult to do it by hand that needs to
be a function hopefully we can get that
for 1003 but there are many other and
other things that we should do and I and
I think one of them was mentioned while
other gentlemen they're about you know
making it easy to kind of to join into
another another data set from from part
of a query
and then they're these operator forms
that have kind of come up in the process
of building data set that are clearly
useful so one is slice another one is
apply through which I could briefly show
you that looks something like this
it's select fan-out you know it takes a
bunch of functions and it applies them
in parallel to an argument not literally
in parallel just conceptually in
parallel there's a lot of room for
optimization so if I'll focus for this
first release was just to get the
semantics right and to make sure that
you know it had the power that and
flexibility that we thought it needed
but this a lot remains a huge amount
that's inefficient about data sets and
the primary thing there is that data
sets have built a common case of of
tables with columns those data sets are
built as lists of associations as I've
drilled home by na and those that's kind
of antithetical to memory use it took to
to lean efficient memory usage and the
reason is that that Association data
structure is sort of quite unnecessary
like you know that they're all the same
you know that they will have the same
keys you don't need to store those keys
again and again again even if you're
sharing pointers the super structure of
the Association is expensive and the
last reason is that you can't store the
values packed if you have a column of
numbers you know we have packed arrays
to make it efficient to store large
lists of numbers and we can't use any of
that functionality because they spread
out across all these associations so the
plan is really straightforward and
should work quite nicely that's to
internally store them and column sort of
column or interred away and then
naturally map any queries you write so
that you don't notice that that's
happening just like we do with packed
arrays like you don't notice that packed
arrays are there they will naturally
unpack themselves if you ever need that
you know if you use a function isn't
written to deal with them the same will
go with these column more into tables
they will just naturally work they'll be
efficient in 99% of cases and the odd
thing that isn't written to take
advantage of them will just see the
write data underneath query planning
with there's lots of optimization we can
do there and the most enticing thing is
to is to is to hook into the warfarin
virtual machine and in future into a
technology
like LVM intermediary representation but
there's you know that's a very big topic
it's still hard to get data into data
set like out of a database it's kind of
very finicky to sort of find the right
way to denormalize a sequel database
relational database into a data set
we're working on ways to make that easy
and when it's easy it should be quite
seamless like you should be able to
write queries that look like they're
built against hierarchical data but are
actually being executed by sequel behind
the scenes and streamed back into
Mathematica they'll be very exciting we
also have an out of memory out of core
kind of solution coming that should make
it possible to deal with datasets that
are far too big to fit in RAM but still
small enough that they can live on disk
and I have zero seconds left so that's
pretty much it yeah thank you